what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so for most of you guys out there
you guys recall gambit as the guy who
just like throws cards and blow stuff up
and it's cool like like okay here's the
cool thing about gamma gambit school
because of his personality not really
because of his powers his powers are
kind of cool
I mean honestly which one of us wouldn't
give to have the power to like charge
kinetic energy and objects and then just
throw them and and blow stuff up like it
would just I mean I would do I make a
youtube channel on that I would be like
okay guys today we're gonna charge we're
gonna charge a baseball and see what
happens
I would so make a youtube channel on
that and like every dude it'd be like a
biggest youtube channel on the planet
you know I would basically be like the
new version of FPSRussia except like you
know I wouldn't have the ATF coming
after me I'd have every intelligence
agency on the planet coming after me
which by the way I'm in a hotel room
that's one of the reasons why I'm
talking quieter than I normally do I
can't be super loud but nonetheless
Gambit as you know him in Marvel Comics
that's not the traditional nature of his
powers that's not the true nature of his
powers at least not historically
speaking anyway when it came to gambit
originally his powers were actually a
lot more complex and he was a lot more
powerful than he is at least at this
current moment and depends on on what
era of comics that you're reading like
if you go when you read the imma buy him
three issues 14 through 16 or you go
read uncanny x-men number 350 you
basically end up learning that in the
beginning
gambits powers were wildly powerful a
game it was insanely powerful so the way
is played out when gammas powers first
manifested it was basically like total
control over the kinetic energy of an
object and he didn't have to touch it in
order to make it explode it wasn't
limited to people it wasn't limited to
like a man I mean objects he could just
like see a thing and then charge the
kinetic kinetic energy into it so it was
more like a telepathic and telekinetic
connection as opposed to just like
charging you know the the kinetic energy
in an object but because I was far more
powerful far too much power for him to
be able to control he in turn traveled
to visit a guy named Nathaniel Essex
also known as mr. sinister and mr.
sinister was a mutant geneticist who has
a very very very long history and we're
not really gonna get into it in this
video but suffice it to say he's the guy
you go to when you want to study
genetics and so gambit was a sinister
and said my mutant powers are beyond my
control you know they're running out of
my control you have to do something to
fix it and so sinister said okay fine
I'll do this
I'm gonna ask you for a favor later on
and you're gonna have to honor that
favor and so a gambit said okay and so
sinister removed a portion of gambits
brain that would allow the powers to
continue on and instead his powers
always remained in check now there was a
point where at least one of the things
we ended up learning you know I want to
say was in gambit vol 3 it was an it was
either issue number 24 with with new son
or it was issues 14 through 16 that led
up to new son but it was it was it was
revealed that this portion of gambits
bringing the sinister had removed he had
preserved in case gambit wanted his the
full totality of his powers back which
he got he actually got that during the
new sons story arc and we'll talk more
about that here in a second but the idea
here was a gambit went forward with his
powers reduced and there were there were
more in control now that begs the
question what would happen if that
didn't happen like what would gambit be
like if he had full and complete and
total control over all his powers and he
wasn't limited by like you know having a
touch an object or something like that
that's new son so new son was a version
of gambit from an alternate reality
where that surgical process never took
place and instead his powers were just
like he was he was almost omnipotent in
terms of the power that he had he wasn't
like universe level reality-warping he
wasn't like the molecule man Owen Reese
but he was powerful enough to like kill
the Phoenix you know to kill Phoenix in
his universe Jean Grey despite all of
her abilities and so on him he was
pretty damn capable what made him so
dangerous was that he could turn himself
into a pure form of energy and then
transcend two different dimensions like
like leave his own reality and go to
other dimensions and different things
like that that's what made him so
dangerous but he's like pure energy in
its most pure form but he can like
detonate objects of any size he could
look at a city for example and say
here's the whole of New York City so
we're going to charge all the kinetic
energy in the whole of New York City the
sewer systems that people who are
walking around the buildings themselves
the subway station the whole nine yards
just detonated all at once and and
anyone it would be insane literally just
all explode he had total control over
the kinetic energy of any object that he
happened to see people inanimate
otherwise that's what made him so
dangerous is because he was so
astronomically powerful he could just
make things explode
now really when it when it comes to that
level of power I mean it wasn't just
that right like it wasn't just making
things exploding that's that's what
that's what made him so cool because he
controlled the kinetic energy of an
object he controlled the motion of an
object so he could like stop people dead
in their tracks and they wouldn't be
able to move or he could make them move
if he wanted to he was just controlling
you know they're they're really the
nature of movement
the energy of a particular object um it
was it was kind of murky waters if I'm
being honest because a hair either way
and he would have just become God I mean
like like somebody who can just touch
anything or can look at anything and
make it explode make Galactus blow up
I'm just really glad just like I hunger
and he shows up to earth and he's like
nope or you can make the earth explode
or make another reality explode in fact
I think that was part of new Suns plan
was to take everybody off earth and then
put him into a different on a new under
a different planet and then destroy the
earth like it was it was crazy in terms
of the kind of power that he had but
when you're talking about someone like
that in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
who the hell can fight him like imagine
Ultron showed up and Ultron was just
like oh man you know I'm doing my thing
like New Sun would he just blown him up
he Incredible Hulk comes running towards
you no new Sun trying to stop him he
just freezes him in motion and it's just
like I mean hey you can't move I mean
I'm not physically holding you back like
I'm just shutting down the movement of
your body that's that's all that is and
The Incredible Hulk would have to fight
against himself now it is the Incredible
Hulk so ultimately his anger would
reached such a high level that he would
just move anyway because that's what he
does you know but but it's it's it's
crazy like being able to control the
movement of objects or making them
explode or turning himself into a pure
source of energy or different things
like that
it's absolutely bonkers and in terms of
the kind of things that he can do that's
what makes it so insane is when it came
to manipulating the the movement of
matter this is why classic gambit would
be so powerful is because take for
example like heat is a classic rule of
chemistry if you want to see how two
elements interact put them and put them
in a beaker and add heat that's all it
is that you put them in a beaker and
heat it makes the the atomic the atoms
just start moving faster and faster and
though the the molecules may break apart
or they'll just start forming other
molecules or whatever you know and the
the chemicals will start bonding you
know just just see what happens but when
you're talking about controlling the
movement of stuff like cold is the
absence of heat absolute zero means
there is no atomic movement on any level
whatsoever and so if if he's able to
control on a fundamental level the
molecular movement of matter the atomic
movement of matter and slowed it down
he can literally create cold that's one
of the things that that that new son did
he could create coal by just slowing
things down to the point where they were
it was just astronomically cold or make
things super hot by like speeding them
up I mean that's that's what the whole
thing of creating an explosive process
was just moving atoms is such an
astronomical rate that they would
explode and that's why characters like
that are weird you know that's why
someone like him couldn't really fit
into the MCU and why he doesn't really
have a place in comics is because you're
basically talking about manipulating the
atomic
sure of matter if only for no other
reason just make it move faster now
that's one of the big big differences
between like okay let's talk about this
for a second because this is an
important thing in Marvel Comics you
have what are called reality war PIRs
and then you have matter manipulators
alright reality Wars are people like
Franklin Richards people like Matthew
Malloy um people you know people who can
basically change reality to make it
whatever it is that they want it to be
the idea here is you have like the law
of conservation of mass right like
matter cannot be created or destroyed
that following the rules of physics when
you die your atoms will be dispersed
across the cosmos to become part of the
background energy of the universe or
they'll become part of the earth and the
dirt or whatever the case is but like
your your atomic structure will go
somewhere when it comes to something to
something like a reality or for like
Franklin or like like Matthew Malloy
that doesn't apply to them they can just
defy the laws of physics they can just
say like I'm gonna create a teacup out
of thin air I'm gonna add matter to this
universe like this universe is composed
of however much matter I'm gonna add to
it because I just want this one
particular thing matter manipulators are
people who can manipulate the
fundamental forces of the universe but
can't actually create or can actually
add to it so like the molecule man was a
matter manipulator he was a matter
manipulator of the highest order at
least he was until it until they they
reckoned his powers and said he was
one-half of a cosmic cube and then he
became a reality warper because he could
just do whatever he wanted to do back in
the old days and the old Fantastic Four
stories when he had his wand and he was
just turning stuff he was a matter
manipulator now again like he became
like a full-fledged reality warper from
Secret Wars going forward but but like
someone like new son like gambit with
his classic powers he's a matter
manipulator he can't really create
anything in the universe right like he
can't really like take something in turn
in you know just create something out of
nothing but if he can speed up and slow
down the movement of atoms there's no
reason to believe he can't shift those
atoms around to make them into something
else to in turn like break molecules
down and then restructure them into
something else and what that would do is
it with rima t realized things he could
turn a human being into a couch a dog
into a porpoise if he wanted to you know
because he's just restructuring their
their genetic material like their atomic
structure into something else he hasn't
actually done that before and so we
can't I mean we would really be jumping
to conclusions if we said that but it
stands to reason that he could because
you're talking about someone just
manipulating the fundamental forces of
the universe by
the atomic structure of matter and
someone is hopeful work but that's why
someone like gambit like classic gambit
and you know new son he wouldn't be able
to work in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
because you're talking about a guy who's
borderline controlling the atomic
structure of matter on a universal scale
yeah that's the thing he doesn't have to
see it he only has to do is to know it's
there and then be able to in turn
control it like it doesn't have to be in
his line of sight no he just has to be
aware of its existence and that's that's
why it wouldn't work it'd be cool but it
wouldn't work because no one would be
able to stop him nobody would be able to
challenge him he would just be unchecked
unrivaled but still you know it's it's
it's a weird situation only that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain make sure you guys to the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you